Les Burgondes:
Bonjour!
Que vous soyez de fidèles abonnés ou que
vous ayez cliqué ici en espérant voir des
-CUILLERES
-Cet épisode est fait pour vous car nous
allons y parler des Burgondes: que sait-on
sur eux?
-D'où venaient-ils?
-Comment vivaient-ils?
-Quel héritage ont-ils laissé?
-Et surtout: appréciaient-ils les fruits
au sirop? C'est parti.
On pense que les Burgondes viennent de l'île
de Bornholm, dans la mer Baltique. Aux Ier
et IIe siècles après J.C., les romains les
appellent Burgundioni ou burgudiones, qui
provient sûrement de l'indo-européen bhrghus
qui signifie grand, haut et fort.
-Fort en pommes.
-Au Ier siècle ils se déplacent dans la
région de la Vistule et la vallée de la
Warta. Ils y vivent tranquillement mais sont
attaqués par un autre peuple: les Gépides,
qui les massacrent fortement et les forcent
à partir vers le Sud-Ouest, près du Danube,
à la frontière de l'Empire romain.
-A l'époque on connaissait vaguement ces
gens, Pline l'Ancien les avait classés dans
la catégorie des Vandales. C'était des germaniques
en somme, mais tant qu'ils ne franchissaient
pas la frontière on avait peu de rapports
avec eux.
-A partir de là, ils vivent donc au bord
de la frontière et en contact avec d'autres
peuples, notamment les Alamans à qui ils
essaient de piquer des bouts de territoire
à plusieurs reprises.
A cette époque leur peuple est divisé en
clans larges. Les clans sont dirigés par
un roi militaire appelé Hendinos. D'après
l'historien Ammien Marcellin, la coutume veut
que ce roi soit déposé si la fortune l'abandonne
à la guerre ou si la récolte vient à manquer.
Chaque clan a aussi un dirigeant religieux
appelé Sinistrus, nommé à vie.
Et voilà à peu près tout ce qu'on sait
d'eux jusqu'au IVe siècle. Les sources archéologiques
nous confirment l'installation des Burgondes
au nord de la Pologne, puis leur migration
à cause du massacre des Gépides.
-Et puis vers 370, ils se sentent pousser
des ailes et fondent le premier royaume burgonde.
Un royaume de barbares, pfff.
II/ La fleur en bouquet fane, et jamais ne
renaît. (extrait)
En effet à la fin du IVe siècle, ils continuent
de se déplacer. Ils conquièrent le territoire
des Alamans dans la vallée du Main, proche
du Rhin.
Durant l'hiver 406 ils profitent que le fleuve
soit gelé pour lancer quelques expéditions
au delà du Rhin, dans l'Empire romain.
Ils ne sont pas les seuls: des Vandales,
des Alains et des Suèves franchissent aussi
les frontières de l'empire à cette époque.
-Ouais, et on sait pas qui est le coupable
parmi tous ces barbares mais les villes de
Worms et Mayence ont été pillées! Et,
ça se fait pas.
-En parlant de Mayence, cette ville a de l'importance
dans la suite de l'histoire puisqu'en 411
trois frères de l'aristocratie locale décident
de prendre le pouvoir avec l'appui des Burgondes:
ils proclament empereur l'un des frères,
Jovin, et s'avancent vers le Sud.
-On se calme tout de suite, messieurs les
barbares: on vous a battus, fin de l'histoire.
-Loin de là: les chefs Burgondes vaincus
négocient avec le général romain et parviennent
à conserver les terres que l'empereur autoproclamé
Jovin leur avait filées. A partir de 413
ils ont donc tout un territoire dans la vallée
du Main mais aussi en Gaule, près du Rhin.
C'est le 1er royaume Burgonde, dont il semblerait
que la capitale ait été Worms.
Dans ce premier royaume, ainsi que ceux qui
ont suivi, le mode de gouvernance était simple:
tous les frères d'une génération régnaient
ensemble, puis quand le dernier mourait les
enfants de l'aîné prenaient le relais etc.
C'est beau la famille.
-Ça sent surtout bon les assassinats entre
frères tout ça.
-Ô familia, familiae...
-En 436 c'est la tristesse et la fin de ce
premier empire à cause des Huns qui envahissent
le pays Burgonde et tuent le grand roi Gundahar.
Il est possible qu'Attila en personne ait
mené cette bataille.
Plusieurs sources romaines racontent cette
bataille, et emploient l'expression «ab
stirpe»...
-Pardon, citation latine, excusez-moi: ab
stirpe signifie dans la langue barbare que
vous utilisez «à la racine», elle semble
donc indiquer ici que les Huns ont détruit
l'élite Burgonde jusqu'à ce qu'il ne reste
aucun héritier mâle dans la famille royale.
Pourquoi pas !
-A la place, on met donc une assemblée burgonde
d'une trentaine de types mais les Burgondes
sont obligés de fuir leur territoire en lui
faisant un signe de la main.
-Parce qu'ils vivaient dans la vallée du
Main. Faites semblant de rire.
-On a retrouvé quelques témoignages archéologiques
de ce premier royaume Burgonde, notamment
un cimetière à Kahl am Main qui nous indique
que la plupart des Burgondes étaient incinérés,
mais à art ça on a du mal à les distinguer
des vestiges des autres barbares de la région.
Passons donc au 2e royaume Burgonde.
Encore une fois ce royaume-là se fait en
accord avec les romains, puisqu'il résulte
d'un traité passé en 443 qui accorde aux
Burgondes la Sapaudia.
-Trop cool! C'est où?
-La Sapaudia signifie Savoie, enfin! Quoique,
ce territoire correspond plutôt au lac Léman,
et au Nord-Est de ce dernier.
-Ouais, donc pas la Savoie quoi. Merci pour
l'info.
-On pense que ces nouveaux burgondes déplacés
étaient entre 25 000 et 50 000.
Par la suite, vers 457, ils agrandissent leur
territoire vers la Gaule. Ils sont alors menés
par le roi Gondioc, qui s'installe à Lyon
et reçoit le titre de magister militum, le
maître de la milice. Parce que les romains,
c'est des copains!
Bien sûr il existait déjà des gens qui
vivaient là, des gallo-romains ou d'autres
peuples... Du coup les Burgondes s'installent
selon le procédé de l'incruste, ils partagent
les terres avec ceux qui étaient déjà là
que ça leur plaise ou pas.
Après Gondioc vient Hilpéric, dont on retiendra
de lui, pour aller à l'essentiel, qu'il meurt
entre 474 et 491.
-Adieu Hilpéric, roi dont on ne parlera pas
par souci d'audience.
-A sa mort ses deux neveux se partagent le
règne, toujours selon le même régime de
succession. Du coup Godegisel prend le territoire
des Burgondes en Sapaudia
-Qui n'est pas la Savoie
-Et Gondebaud a tout le reste, parce que c'est
l'aîné. Tout ceci ressemble à un mauvais
scénario où le petit frère va se rebeller
pour avoir le reste des terres, et c'est ce
qui va se passer. Mais patience.
D'abord Gondebaud marie sa nièce Clothilde
à Clovis, un mec vaguement connu si vous
avez suivi un peu les cours d'histoire à
l'école.
-Un jour, il s'est fait baptiser.
-Certains chroniqueurs ont raconté qu'avant
de marier Clothilde, Gondebaud avait massacré
ses parents et l'avait fait séquestrer à
Genève où des ambassadeurs de Clovis l'auraient
aperçue et auraient rapporté à leur empereur
-eh, y'a une meuf pas mal à Genève!
-Mais, euh... C'est un peu bizarre cette histoire.
On sait pas pourquoi il aurait fait ça donc
c'est peut-être une confusion avec un autre
événement... En tout cas la loi Burgonde
prévoit effectivement des peines de responsabilité
familiale, où on tue aussi la femme et les
fils de plus de 14 ans de quelqu'un qui aurait
vraiment déconné. Donc ma foi,
Pourquoi pas !
Donc, les burgondes nouent des liens avec
les francs, et ça tombe bien parce que vers
500 Godegisel en a marre d'avoir les plus
petites terres du royaume: son frère approche
la cinquantaine et ne semble toujours pas
décidé à mourir, donc il demande l'aide
de Clovis et marche sur le royaume de Gondebaud.
C'est la guerre!
Quand Gondebaud voit la coalition de son frère
et de Clovis il se barre, Clovis l'assiège
à Avignon et lui impose de lui verser un
tribut annuel.
Mais c'est pas fini! Une fois Clovis reparti,
Gondebaud assiège Vienne où se trouve son
frère et tue ledit frère, ses partisans,
noie sa femme, tue ses neveux, jette tout
le monde dans un puits et fait enfermer les
filles.
-La famille.
-Après ça Gondebaud est libre d'unifier
le royaume burgonde, tranquille.
Il meurt en 516, et c'est Sigismond qui lui
succède. Lui est plus posé que son père,
plus réfléchi...
-Il fait étrangler son fils en 522 sur un
coup de tête, et regrette le soir même.
-Regard gêné.
-Oh, mais je me souviens de ça! Ça ne
serait pas l'événement qui marque le début
de la fin pour les burgondes?
-Si. Ce meurtre affaiblit le royaume parce
qu'il pose problème à l'aristocratie burgonde
sur plusieurs niveaux: déjà parce qu'un
meurtre, c'est punissable par la loi; ensuite
parce qu'il a tué un héritier potentiel,
c'est peu malin, et enfin parce que ça fait
douter de la capacité du roi à gouverner.
-Sans déconner.
-Les fils de Clovis décident alors de conquérir
toute la Gaule, et commencent par le royaume
Burgonde. Ce qui est légitime puisqu'ils
sont Burgondes de par leur mère. Ils tuent
Sigismond et sa famille mais ne prennent pas
le royaume tout de suite.
C'est Godomar, le frère de Sigismond, qui
prend le royaume en main à partir de 524
et lui vraiment est plus posé! Il réunit
une assemblée, proclame des édits pour ramener
la situation à la normale en repeuplant les
campagnes par exemple. Il rachète les prisonniers
emmenés par les Francs et les esclaves qui
avaient été capturés sont libérés et
autorisés à s'installer dans le royaume.
Mais ce bonheur ne dure pas, en 532 les fils
de Clovis reviennent et battent définitivement
les burgondes dans la région d'Autun. Godomar
s'enfuit et on ne le revoit jamais, le deuxième
royaume burgonde prend fin et est intégré
au royaume des francs mais comme ces francs
avaient aussi du sang burgonde en eux tout
ça reste une histoire de famille et de guerre
entre cousins.
Encore une fois on conserve peu de vestiges
de ce deuxième royaume, parce qu'on n'arrive
pas vraiment à distinguer les vestiges francs
des autres. On trouve des restes autour de
la région d'Annecy, Dijon, Chalon sur Saône...
En plus à l'époque Burgonde on était revenus
à des constructions en bois plutôt qu'en
pierre, donc éclate-toi à les retrouver
1500 ans après.
Les trous de poteaux....
Tout ceci était fort chronologique, alors
on va maintenant revenir sur quelques points
qui nous permettent d'appréhender la culture
burgonde.
Vous avez pu remarquer que dès le premier
royaume Burgonde, les liens avec l'empire
romain étaient plutôt resserrés. A partir
de leur installation en Sapaudia, les Burgondes
participent à plusieurs reprises à des batailles
au côté de l'armée romaine.
Ça amène parfois à des particularités
comme une bataille contre l'armée d'Attila
près de Troyes, en 450, où les burgondes
de Sapaudia affrontent d'autres burgondes
dans le camp d'Attila, qui s'étaient soumis
aux Huns à l'époque du premier royaume Burgonde.
Dès le début de la bataille, c'est déjà
le merdieeeer
Au sein de la famille royale, les enfants
reçoivent une culture classique et parlent
latin. Les rois Burgondes se considèrent
comme des lieutenants de l'empereur de Rome,
puisque celui-ci leur avait donné le titre
de magister militum, et frappent monnaie à
son effigie.
Tout n'est pas toujours rose non plus dans
les relations entre burgondes et gallo-romains:
comme je le disais précédemment, les Burgondes
installés en Gaule obtiennent des terres
de l'empereur mais des gens vivaient déjà
dessus. Ils s'installent donc sur la base
de l'hospitalité: dans la loi Burgonde
il est dit que deux tiers des terres et un
tiers des esclaves sont alloués aux burgondes.
-C'est de la bonne hospitalité.
-Les historiens se demandent si les burgondes
ont vraiment raflé une partie des terres
et des esclaves de la région, ou s'ils ont
juste reçu le droit de prélever des impôts
dessus. Ça paraîtrait plus logique, parce
qu'on imagine qu'il y aurait eu pas mal de
révoltes de la part des locaux sinon.
On a quand même des burgondes qui s'installent
sur des terres romaines, où vivent des romains,
et la cohabitation n'est pas toujours aisée.
L'écrivain gallo-romain Sidoine Apollinaire
reçoit ainsi quelques dizaines de burgondes
sur ses terres. A l'occasion du mariage d'un
ami, il rédige un poème dans lequel on sent
qu'il avait besoin de se lâcher sur ses hôtes.
«Pourquoi me demandes-tu de composer – en
serais-je même capable?
Un poème en l'honneur de Vénus amie des
chants fescennins
Quand je vis au milieu de hordes chevelues,
Que j'ai à supporter leur langage germanique
Et à louer incontinent, malgré mon humeur
noire,
Les chansons du Burgonde gavé,
Qui s'enduit les cheveux de beurre rance?
Heureux tes yeux et tes oreilles,
Heureux aussi ton nez,
Toi qui n'as pas à subir l'odeur de l'ail
ou de l'oignon infect
Que renvoient dès le petit matin dix préparations
culinaires,
Toi qui n'est pas assailli, avant même le
lever du jour,
Comme si tu étais leur vieux grand-père
ou le mari de leur nourrice,
Par une foule de Géants si nombreux et si
grands
Qu'à peine les contiendrait la cuisine d'Alcinoüs.»
-POPOPO
Le texte le plus important qu'on conserve
des Burgondes est la loi Burgonde, aussi appelée
loi Gombette puisqu'elle est promulguée par
le roi Gondebaud vers 502. Ce recueil de lois
pose les bases du droit civil et criminel
dans le royaume burgonde, et réalise une
belle fusion entre le droit romain et germanique.
C'est le premier recueil de lois d'un roi
germanique en Gaule, ceux des Francs et des
Wisigoths sont plus tardifs.
En fait Gondebaud fait rédiger deux lois:
la lex Burgundionum qui concerne les burgondes
et les cas entre burgondes et autres peuples,
et la lex romana Burgundionum qui concerne
les cas entre gallo-romains uniquement sur
le territoire Burgonde.
La loi burgonde est surtout constituée de
droit romain, mais apporte aussi des usages
burgondes: le wittimon, par exemple, est
la somme versée par le fiancé à la famille
de sa future femme, et le morgingabe désigne
les biens donnés par le mari à sa femme
le lendemain du mariage. On trouve aussi des
compensations payables pour les blessures
et les meurtres, des lois sur la violence,
le vol, le mariage, le divorce, les successions...
La loi parle beaucoup des esclaves, et aussi
des femmes: l'autorité des mères de famille
y est reconnue, et c'est la seule loi qui
permet aux femmes d'être tutrices de leurs
enfants mineurs tant qu'elles ne se remarient
pas.
-Enfin à côté de ça elle prévoit de tuer
la femme d'un mec condamné à quelque chose
de vraiment grave, donc faut pas s'emballer.
La loi Burgonde est retravaillée par Sigismond
et Godomar, les rois suivants, et reste en
place longtemps après la fin du deuxième
royaume burgonde.
-Evidemment, elle est faite de droit romain,
donc forcément faite pour durer.
-Rappelle-nous comment allait l'empire romain
au Ve siècle?
C'est ce que je pensais.
On ne peut pas parler de culture burgonde
sans aborder leur religion: à la base,
les Burgondes étaient polythéistes, mais
ils se convertissent vers 428 à l'arianisme,
une forme de christianisme. Cette religion
reste bien implantée chez les Burgondes durant
le Ve siècle, même si dans la famille royale
la plupart des reines et princesses rapportées
étaient catholiques.
Le premier roi Burgonde à se convertir au
catholicisme est Sigismond, vers 500. Du coup
comme on n'est pas sûrs de la date du baptême
de Clovis, il est possible qu'il se soit converti
avant lui.
-Déso pour la postérité.
-Sigismond est tellement catho qu'il fonde
une abbaye à Saint-Maurice d'Agaune en 515,
parce que ça fait toujours bien, au moment
du bilan de son règne, de dire qu'on a fondé
une abbaye.
-Et qu'on a tué son fils.
-Non.
Cette conversion n'est toutefois pas représentative
de l'ensemble du peuple Burgonde, qui reste
largement arien durant le VIe siècle.
Maintenant, si vous rêviez de devenir interprète
Burgonde, je vous préviens: ça va être
compliqué. On sait qu'il existait une langue
burgonde, mais on en connaît très peu de
choses. Les quelques mots qu'on connaît étaient
écrits en alphabet latin, ce qui nous permet
de constater que c'était une langue germanique.
Les Burgondes parlaient aussi le bas-latin,
et dès le VIIIe siècle la langue burgonde
semble avoir été remplacée par un mélange
de latin, burgonde et franc.
Si vous voulez vous la péter, sachez que
chef de famille se dit faraman et peuple:
leudis.
-Et «chambre souterraine», c'est screunia.
-Bravo, vous êtes interprète burgonde et
désolé: je ne sais pas comment on dit
cuillère en Burgonde.
Interprèèète
Dans les noms des Burgondes, on retrouve aussi
des éléments germaniques. La loi Burgonde
est d'ailleurs très précieuse à ce sujet
puisqu'on y trouve les noms de 32 comtes burgondes.
Du coup, on connaît leurs noms.
Les suffixes et préfixes des noms burgondes
ont une signification, on retrouve souvent
des noms commençant par bald pour hardi,
Sigi pour victoire, Theod pour peuple, Vulf
pour loup... Chez les femmes la mode est à
Berga qui signifie protection ou Leuba qui
signifie cher, aimé.
Les noms dans la famille royale se transmettent
des parents aux enfants: par exemple du
roi Gibica au roi Gondebaud, en passant par
Gondioc... Le nom commence par un G, bien
vu.
Et ensuite Sigismond, dont le nom signifie
victoire, nomme son fils Sigisric. Mais il
finit par le tuer, si vous avez suivi, donc
victoire mes fesses.
Et on a à peu près fait le tour de la culture
Burgonde, je sais c'est triste, mais si Kaamelott
avait raison sur un point: c'est celui-là.
-Des barbares, on vous dit! Ils ne savaient
que boire et chanter, et leur nourriture sentait
horriblement fort! Ils faisaient mijoter
leur ragoût pendant des heures et ne mangeaient
même pas de fromage.
-Pardon?!
-Ben, oui, c'est Sidoine Apollinaire qui me
l'a raconté.
Pas changer assiette pour fromage !
-Un mythe s'effondre.
-Bref, en dehors de ça on sait que les Burgondes
travaillaient bien le bois, d'ailleurs la
spécialisation moderne du Jura en horlogerie,
fabrique de jouets... Pourrait venir d'eux.
On a retrouvé certains objets burgondes,
des épées, des petites haches, des pointes
de javelots et de lances, des fibules... Mais
on ne connaît pas vraiment l'armement des
burgondes. Comme ils étaient intégrés à
l'armée romaine, on suppose qu'ils étaient
équipés comme des membres de l'armée romaine.
Les hommes portaient des tuniques jusque mi-cuisse
et des braies, ainsi que des manteaux qui
étaient des sortes de capes attachées sur
l'épaule comme les romains.
-Imitateurs.
Et dernier point pas très reluisant sur la
culture burgonde: ils pratiquaient, comme
plusieurs autres peuples de l'époque, la
déformation de la boîte crânienne des enfants.
Qu'est-ce à dire que ceci?
-Fais pas l'innocent, monsieur le burgonde,
on sait que vous mettiez des bandeaux sur
les têtes de vos enfants pour leur donner
des crânes pointus ou allongés.
-Ça n'est pas chez les romains qu'on trouverait
des pratiques pareilles.
L'histoire des Burgondes ne s'arrête pas
à la défaite de Godomar en 532: même
si le deuxième royaume Burgonde n'existe
plus, les personnes qui vivent sur le territoire
burgonde... Sont toujours burgondes, et s'en
revendiquent.
Vers 536, un noble burgonde demande l'autorisation
de sortir les restes du roi Sigismond et sa
femme du puits dans lequel ils avaient été
jetés après leur mort, histoire de quand
même leur rendre hommage.
-Même s'il avait tué son fils.
Vers la même époque le partage des terres
du royaume franc attribue la Burgondie à
Gontran, l'un des petits-fils de Clovis, qui
entretient la légitimité Burgonde puisqu'il
a ça dans le sang et que son nom a une racine
Burgonde.
Le nom de «Burgundia», ou Burgondie,
entre dans l'usage courant après la fin du
2e royaume Burgonde.
En 888, Rodophe, le fils d'un comte local,
décide de devenir libre et indépendant et
fonde le 3e royaume burgonde.
-Oui, enfin rien à voir avec les deux précéd...
-Hého, on est en 888, t'es périmée la romaine!
Laisse les grands parler!
-Bref, ce troisième royaume Burgonde se termine
en 1032. Durant cette période on sait que
la loi Burgonde était encore utilisée.
Même si les premiers royaumes burgondes avaient
disparu depuis longtemps et si les burgondes
avaient eu le temps de se mélanger avec tous
les autres peuples locaux, leur territoire
est donc toujours considéré comme une entité
à part, il reste une sorte de «sentiment
national burgonde» puis bourguignon que
revendiquent même les ducs de Bourgogne du
XVe siècle.
-Philippe le Hardi, Jean sans Peur, Philippe
le Bon, Charles le Téméraire.
-Dans la toponymie, les noms de lieux, on
retrouve la marque des Burgondes un peu partout:
la Bourgogne, déjà, de manière assez évidente,
qui s'appelait Burgundia à l'époque franque.
Il existe aussi des villes comme Bourguignon-lès-Conflans,
Bourguignon-lès-Morey.
D'autres villes ont des noms issus de mots
germaniques qui ont probablement été rapportés
par les burgondes:
le mot «fare», qui signifie famille,
se retrouve à Montferrand la Fare dans la
Drôme, La Fère dans l'Aisne, Lafare dans
le Vaud... On retrouve aussi l'élément vulf,
qui signifie loup, dans les villes de Voufflange,
Vufflens-la-ville, etc.
Les Burgondes demeurent aussi par d'autres
moyens: on les retrouve par exemple dans
plusieurs eddas et sagas nordiques écrites
entre le IXe et le XIIIe siècle, donc bien
après leur disparition. Ils figurent notamment
dans l'Edda de Snorri, probablement la plus
célèbre, mais aussi dans le Nibelungenlied,
l'épopée qui a inspiré l'opéra de Wagner.
Les personnages sont fictifs, mais il est
possible que la grosse défaite subie par
les Burgondes en 436, celle qui les conduit
à fuir leur premier royaume, ait inspiré
la «malédiction des nibelungen».
-Dans beaucoup d'eddas, l'histoire finit mal.
Comme les Burgondes en 436. Donc c'est lié,
voilà.
Voilà, j'espère que ce petit tour dans le
Haut Moyen-Âge vous a plu. Pour cet épisode
je me suis aidée des travaux de Katalin Escher,
qui a écrit plusieurs livres sur les Burgondes
malgré le peu de sources dont on dispose
à leur sujet.
Je vais sûrement faire une petite pause pendant
l'été puisque je serai à Montbazon le week-end
du 22 juillet et je risque de pas mal bouger
ensuite, mais si vous êtes de la partie vous
pourrez venir me voir le dimanche à 12h15
pour une conférence sur le Bon et le Mauvais
sorcier!
Oubliez pas
la crème solaire et le chapeau de paille,
c'est assez vital.
A bientôt, bisous, abonnez-vous et tout!